no what is what is this what is this
flying no
no no no
[Music]
i don't really want to talk about dune i
want to talk about
art art is art is important
and i will never pretend to understand
what art is
and means but what i do understand
is science fiction book covers sort of
and one of the most important science
fiction book covers and maybe
works of art graphic art in my life
is right here this is the version of
dude and i bought back
way long ago say what you will about
this cover it definitely
has a kind of blandness to it
slightly but also a kind of prestige
quality to it i always loved this cover
maybe just because this was the cover in
bookstores when i
read dune and when i was interested in
dune this got me thinking about
dune cover art segway today i
am rating and reviewing all of the dune
hover art that is out there or at least
the cover art that appears in this
website
i found probably the perfect website for
that hold on let me put on my old man
glasses
this is an article called book cover
trends through time
via duned by lauren panipinto
panapinto i'm sorry if i'm butchering
that uh wouldn't it be
fun wouldn't it be just delightful if i
went through these covers and
rated them and i thought it'd be a nice
tour through science fiction history
the spectrum of wonderful and
horrendous because there's not really a
middle ground how will i be rating this
five is great one is
dog [ __ ] i was breathing so [ __ ] hard
so the first covers i'm looking at
are from the pre-book history dune was
first serialized in a magazine
early 1960s this was the very first
piece of dune art you know it's it's
it's fine it's not what i picture when i
think of dune
there's a big piece of rock it kind of
looks like it could be any
science fiction story see i'm a great
art critic i could
i could do this i mean it's pretty it's
it's very pretty but it doesn't make me
think of dune it doesn't i wouldn't if i
saw this i wouldn't think
dune you know i think we have to wait
later for that which is wonderful
because
the next two illustrations these might
be my favorite
dune images period one is the sand worm
which with that three pronged
you know sand worm mouth it's just great
you have these figures huddled you have
the sense of scale the colors are just
so
bombastic and so evocative kind of artsy
and then the second one
is what became the actual dune cover is
also very artsy and
and beautiful and mysterious this kind
of carries me into the first edition of
dune
this cover of dune was unique
in that it wasn't trying to sell this
science fiction
aspect science fiction not typically
taken seriously at the time
and was published hardcover to give this
sense of prestige a lot of science
fiction was just straight to paperback
this hardcover edition of dune was
trying to say
i'm important listen to me and the cover
is kind of doing the same thing
you can't immediately tell that this is
science fiction just based on the cover
there's no there's no sand worms or
anything there's people going through
this
kind of desert and what i always loved
about this cover is that it's not never
what i expected the first cover of dune
to look like but when you look at it
it's just
perfect i love how frank herbert's name
is in yellow font of dune
is just this swirly psychedelic thing
and then the image is just
the texture of the paint you can just
feel it's very
painterly i don't know can i say that or
is that pretentious
it's pretentious but i'm gonna say god
it's gorgeous the reds you know the red
just
seeping off of the painting it's just
amazing
the longer i look at this piece of art
the more i'm just mesmerized even though
not much is depicted in it it just
you get this kind of mystical exciting
dune vibe that we all know and love just
gosh
i i love this i love this cover so much
and apparently there was a map of
arrakis
on the back which is so cool original
cover
five out of five perfect no complaints
the first paperback edition though
i'm gonna have to go with a solid three
you know it's great i like the font i
like the
the rocks are nice but it's very it's
not as
evocative it feels a bit more simple and
yeah it looks like it could just be
a book about any old desert who wants to
read that i sure don't
now the first editions for the rest of
the series i'm going to get into
because oh boy are they chef's kiss that
is such an old meme
but i don't care messiah i believe there
is a different artist
it's fine actually seems like dune
messiah they are kind of going for
pulpy sci-fi back into this pulpy sci-fi
the first one has this very artsy cover
the second one is very like i don't know
what that
that thing is that bug-like thing is
that a thoppeter or the birds like
the head i don't there's so much going
on here it gives me kind of beneath
the planet of the apes vibe planet of
the apes fans you know what i mean two
out of five children of dune
i like it a bit more this is actually
the introduction apparently of this
famous dune font you know it's pretty
good uh three out of five i don't have
much to say about it
god emperor of dune first cover
um i think they did the best they could
probably with the concept a little more
abstract a little
fuzzy i actually like it quite a bit it
doesn't have the same kind of
power of that that original cover but
it's pretty good i'm gonna say
four out of five heretics of dune i'm
really meh
on this one maybe it's because i don't
fully know what's going on in this image
i'm gonna have to say 2.5
it's okay chapter house dune i really
like this one i think it's the same
artist who did the original dune cover
that's that's a pretty cover
that is a weird circular thing i have no
clue what that's supposed to be
but i'm here for it i'm here for all of
this what are those things like
obelisks do you know what i love about
chapter house dune that colon i love a
good
a well-placed colon and a title chapter
house
dune i haven't read the book but
i'm sure the art is fitting next we've
got the 70s
and 80s paperbacks we have this cover
of dune i'm getting 70s vibes the face
the clothes okay not really what i think
of dune
but it's certainly unique and i really
like that
i'm going to go with a three out of five
now um this is kind of the showstopper
because i think this dune messiah cover
is
[ __ ] amazing it's so trippy and
bizarre you know the big panorama on the
back you have these
flying saucers with these people on top
of them it gives me this kind of the
michael whelan
cover art for the martian chronicles the
ray bradbury ones
it seems kind of like a similar pose for
some reason this cover is just dune
messiah to me this is dune messiah i
didn't picture any of these
images when i read the book but after i
read the book and i looked at this cover
i was like yes
this is a solid five out of five
straight up there was
another printing that came out the 80s
oh boy
do i have opinions um i'm gonna put them
all up here
together ah yeah i'm not i'm not loving
this
the sand worms are [ __ ] up there's
kind of cool colors in there but yeah
it doesn't work for me i don't like the
font why are the sand worms blue
the 80s were [ __ ] man god emperor of
dune no
no what is what is this what is this
flying and no
no no no no heretics of dune what are
those tube things that hamsters crawl
through that's what the sand worms look
like in this
i do not i don't know thank god i wasn't
alive in this time because i would not
have
touched these books that's hyperbole and
i apologize to people who like these
covers you know what i'm sure if i grew
up with these covers i would like them
because that's kind of how
tastes work one out of five next ones
that
are close to my heart also because these
are the ones i checked out this dune
messiah one from my college library it
looks like they reworked
most of the original dune cover art
they [ __ ] slap these are the best
paperback copies of dune
i don't love the actual dune cover
though
of these paperbacks i don't like how
there's like skyscrapers in the back
like this just looks like phoenix
arizona dune messiah
huge step up from the original the head
is better there's no flying [ __ ] around
it i like how all these
books have the same font also children
of dune
it's whatever it's fine god emperor of
dune
this is a five out of five out of this
series you got these people standing
there with their arms up like whoa
whoa like easy there pal i love how it's
the worm is like
coated in like steel plating i don't
know why
at least that's what it looks like it's
so [ __ ] weird i want
that makes me want to read god emperor
of dune this instant
heretics of dune this one is gorgeous i
mean that's another five out of five
out of this series the worm and how the
guy
is just like moses just like controlling
the worm at least that's what it looks
like to me does moses make an appearance
in
heretics of dune possibly chapter house
dune
great original cover art overall this
whole collection of paperbacks
five out of five alright so we have a
few other ones frank herbert's classic
dune
oh no i'm not even i'm not gonna comment
on this
it's [ __ ] awesome i'll i'll just say
that now these ones
i really love these they don't have the
typical
dune font but this font works
great and all of the art it coheres all
of these covers that's what i love about
it these are five out of fives
these are really gorgeous the colors the
contrast the mood
they all kind of look similar i wouldn't
really be able to pull
each one out from each other it's fine
because they are just
you know i'd say chapter house dune
probably has the worst one the dune and
heretics of dune ones really those are
those are look really good and the god
emperor of dune man
that's like jesus worm all right now
we're into the
probably one that is very fond to a lot
of people which is the
movie tie-in from the 80s what can you
say i think it's
i think it's great this doesn't look as
[ __ ] stupid as a lot of the movie
tie-ins that
books get these days with just like
actors faces on it like the lord of the
rings movie tie-ins give me a [ __ ]
break
but this movie tie-in it you you don't
even think that it's
a movie tie-in because it's just so
discreet on the top just the
best-selling science fiction novel
now a movie beyond your imagination i
love it i love the colors it's just
that's a solid four out of five now i'm
going to skip overhead
two 2000s now the author of this article
says that they
play too safe for their liking and feel
generic these are the editions of the
books that i fell in love with the
original dune
it's the only one that has an actual
photograph on it which is a little weird
but it looks classy
it really does dune messiah i like that
they
incorporate the original art it was
probably
a cost saving method i think it looks
nice children of dune
that one looks pretty good god emperor
of dune man
i think they improved the cover the old
paperback cover
the silver the it's just weird as hell
like you're missing part of the image
like it feels like there's more to be
seen there's more you want to see in
this picture of this worm god
heretics of dune beautiful chapter has
doing great they are classy
they are very 2000s i i love these
copies i wish honestly that i could
still buy these copies
you know i should have got them when i
had the chance because now we have moved
to a new era
now we have moved to a very minimalist
style
i know a lot of people love these new
covers
there's a certain quality i miss plays
it really safe i think
and that's fine they're not like stuff
that i just want to look at them all day
or i just want to explore the images or
i feel transported to another world you
know it just feels like oh this is a
pretty
thing i can place on my bookshelf it's
going to look nice in the background
right i mean it looks good it looks
pretty classy there's there's a certain
genesecua that is absent i see why
people love them and i think they're
they're worthy of love and i you know
maybe upon reading this
i'll have spent enough time with the
cover art to go man those are
beautiful great covers there's also this
new edition that everyone talks about
and loves i think it's the
40th 50th anniversary edition yeah all
right people might
hate me for this but i really really
really dislike this book cover the text
maybe reminds me a bit of like a
dinosaur themed book
i don't like the way the guy's staring
into the camera like that
just looks like very hollywood postery
feels too
modern maybe that's my problem maybe i
am stuck in the past what does that say
about me
who the [ __ ] knows and that's that
what do you what do people think huh do
you do you like the new covers
do you like the old covers what's the
best era of dune
book covers is there stuff i didn't
touch on are there foreign covers that
look
much better i don't know just let me
know what you think thanks for watching
like and subscribe and yeah that's all i
got to say